[Música]
hoy vamos a utilizar una de las
herramientas más potentes del ser humano
la imaginación
lo primero que necesito que hagamos es
que cerremos nuestros ojos pero no los
vayan a abrir hasta que no les digamos
vamos a dejarnos llevar por la
imaginación
ahora que ya todos tienen cerrados sus
ojos
empecemos a imaginar que volvemos a
nacer
pero esta vez nacemos en un pequeño
pueblo de colombia no está alejado del
ruido está alejado de las grandes
ciudades y está escondido entre la selva
y el mar
es hermoso está lleno de verdes y azules
mágicos cargada de quebradas de cascadas
de ríos y los atardeceres la
arquitectura y la comida son increíbles
tantos que podrían dejar sin aliento
cualquiera que lo visite
podemos imaginarnos cualquier pueblo de
colombia de cualquier parte del mundo
realmente no importa lo que importa es
que sea un pequeño pueblo de besòs donde
todos se conocen entre sí donde el
sentimiento de unión permanece intacto
ahora imaginemos que somos niños nos
gusta nadar en esos ríos nos gusta
recorrer esos senderos
y nos gusta compartir con nuestras
familias con nuestros amigos o
simplemente nos gustaba sentarnos a
contemplar los inmensos paisajes que hay
en nuestro hogar y sentir esa paz y esa
tranquilidad que eso nos transmite
pero con los años y mientras crece
empiezan los problemas llegan los grupos
armados comienza la violencia estás un
poco confundido y no sabes que lo que
está pasando comienzas a notar que
algunos vecinos empiezan a desaparecer y
otros más a mudarse a las grandes
ciudades en busca de nuevas
oportunidades
pero las cosas no terminan ahí los ríos
empezaron a secarse los cultivos de los
que depende tú y tu familia se ponen muy
inestables porque el clima cambio y no
sabes qué hacer
pasan los años
todo en tu hogar vuelve y vuelve la
tranquilidad
ya eres adulto los fusiles se han
silenciado y llega lo que muchos llaman
la esperanza del posconflicto realmente
tu pueblo está más tranquilo pero tú en
vez de sentir esperanza sientes más
incertidumbre
en este punto creo que podemos abrir los
ojos y hacer una pequeña reflexión
cierto que suena como una situación muy
aterradora es verdad suena bastante
aterrador y bastante completo pero
desafortunadamente esta no es una
situación hipotética es una realidad sí
y es una realidad que debe cambiar y
creemos que el turismo responsable debe
ser el motor que impulse ese cambio
creemos firmemente que invitar a los
viajeros amantes de la aventura y la
naturaleza a descubrir la colombiana
explorada es la mejor forma de reactivar
las economías locales y fomentar el
desarrollo de las comunidades es cierto
pero explique moles a qué te refieres
con la cola bien explorada ok
la colombiana explorada son todos estos
pueblos municipios y corregimientos que
a raíz del conflicto o el abandono
estatal han estado desconectados de
colombia y el resto del mundo y que ven
en el ecoturismo una alternativa de auto
de sostenibilidad es es cierto pero
siendo realistas aún muchos viajeros
siguen
porque esos pueblos históricamente
marginados existen
y los que han oído hablar de ellos
realmente no saben ni cómo llegar a
quedarse o qué hacer y además aún me
tiene un poco de mí a visitarlos sí es
cierto eso es como el el primer impacto
que uno que se encuentra pero por esa
razón es que nace de travel grafía
un lugar donde las personas se pueden
conectar con todos estos municipios que
tienen la necesidad de volver a la luz
pública y reconectarse con el país
nosotros creemos que podemos conectar la
colombiana explorada con el resto del
país y llenar los espacios y los vacíos
informativos que hay a través de nuestra
bitácora de viaje también hemos creado
un blog colaborativo en el que más de 60
viajeros de todo el mundo se han animado
a contarnos sus historias invitando a
cientos de personas a descubrir nuevos
ríos a entrarse a selvas en desiertos y
en parque national parques nacionales
que antes eran corredores de guerra
esta iniciativa nació de tres jóvenes
caleños miguel está por ahí sentado
y ha tenido tanto pero tanto impacto que
en estos dos años de trabajo nuestras
guías de viajes se han leído casi un
millón y medio de veces en redes
sociales acumulamos el apoyo de 60.000
personas
y realmente para llegar a tener un
impacto real en esas poblaciones
vulnerables que antes le hablábamos y
las que ustedes se imaginaron
necesitamos traspasar las fronteras
necesitamos ir más allá y dejar de ser
un medio meramente informativo
necesitamos sembrar las semillas en cada
uno de ustedes que cada uno puede ser un
agente de cambio de su rol de viajero
les explico un agente de cambio es aquel
que en su diario vivir y en sus viajes
se comporta con responsabilidad es aquel
que cuida de las fuentes hídricas es
aquel que es respeta las normas las
organizaciones locales y es aquel que
sabe que con pequeñas acciones puede
contribuir a un cambio al cambio de
miles de familias campesinas e indígenas
ya que su realidad mejora porque
nosotros sabemos que ustedes y nosotros
podemos ser un agente de cambio porque
viajar va mucho más allá de moverse de
un lugar a otro muchas gracias
[Aplausos]